as the coronavirus pandemic began  sweeping through europe  bergamo was one of the first cities to  be inundated by covet-19 cases  its hospital and healthcare workers were  stretched  the pandemic highlighted weaknesses in  healthcare systems across the eu  today the hospital is better prepared  for the second wave  and treatments for covid19 patients have  improved  the european parliament wants the new eu  for health program to be ambitious  and ensure european systems can face  future health threats  address medicine shortages focus on  disease prevention  and promotes well-being the u.s citizens  should welcome  this program because this will improve  the resilience  of the healthcare systems in the union  by reducing health inequalities by  promoting digitalization  by giving support european commission  for you beating cancer plan for instance  meps want eu for health to improve  cooperation between eu countries  to better deal with future crises  [Music]  generally